hello everyone and welcome to a
wonderful attacking game from the
penultimate round of this year's
European individual Championship it is a
Romanian Grand Master Constantin
lupolescu against the international
master from Azerbaijan Ahmad and it
features uh at the benoni defense which
is interesting in itself and it's always
interesting to see how to play against
the binary defense because it's been
it's been a favorite opening of uh many
strong players throughout history like
Kasparov played the modern Grand Masters
play at Bobby Fischer played it uh Bobby
Fisher even employed it in His World
Chess Championship match against Boris
pasta in game three he won a very nice
game uh I think Bobby Fischer never lost
a game with the with the benoni defense
other than the the one he played against
uh spotsky in the 1992 rematch in sweaty
Stefan uh but that was uh wasn't
organized under fide so it was a very
it's a very strong opening and here you
will see uh just how one slide
imprecision can just make the entire uh
position should explode so let's check
it out uh Constantine has the white
pieces and he opens with D4 we have
Knight to F6 C4 and C5 this is the
benoni defense we have D5 E6 Knight to
C3 and the captors on D5 this is the
Modern Man only very standard stuff C
captures D6 E4 and pawn to G6 Bishop to
E2 with Bishop to G7 and now Knight to
F3 so all modern uh Theory castles and
now usually everyone just castles here
but here we have Bishop to E3 first
postponing Castles by a move and this is
the line which makes uh the game a lot
more interesting with Pawn to B5 now
also a standard idea uh you want to get
a white away from the defense of the E4
pawn and it doesn't matter how you do if
Knight captures then you just capture an
E4 and if Bishop captures you're still
gonna capture an E4 that's the idea if
Knight captures Queen to A5 with the
check you're gonna block Queen D2 Queen
Caprice and B5 now stops castling and
even if Knight captures on D6 you will
still prevent white from castles and
attack the Knight on D6 but you don't
have to do that you could also play
Queen captures and B2 you could trade
Queens let's take captures captures Rook
B1 Bishop C3 chain 92
um yeah and now Bishop T6 again stop why
from from castling so this is all um a
very known stuff and it's not good to
capture this Pawn even though some
people play it so here we have Pawn to
E5 this is the main idea of the position
uh you uh attacked the Knight on E6 and
you try to create a past D Pawn if you
create that then already you are very
very close to having a great game uh
here we have D captures an E5 Bishop
captures and C5 now attacking The Rook
Rook to E8 and the bishop characters and
B5 attacking The Rook once again and now
we have Pawn to E4 uh here Ahmad does
not want to try to save the Roku or play
something like 97 to save The Rook while
develop the piece he wants to go for the
attack here and again there's nothing
wrong with this uh I'm sure you can play
this uh Bishop capture 78 you don't have
to capture you could also keep the
tension with Knight and E4 but Bishop
capture 78 with e captures and F3 now
Bishop captures an F7 a nice in between
move as of course you you don't want to
just give up the bishop for nothing uh
with check King captures now Queen
captures on F3 and now uh the way to
play this as you can see
uh black really has to start developing
pieces so it would be best to do
something like Bishop G4 and once you
move the Knight to D7 attack the bishop
so everything should come into game uh
with Tempo but here at night the A6 was
played which also comes into the game
with Tempo okay the bishop on C5 is
hanging uh but it is uh much much
different Bishop to D4 now and here
comes Knight to B4 and there's just no
coming back from this Knight to the B4
move okay you are threatening Knight to
C2 to attack The Rook the king and the
bishop it will be a wonderful Fork uh
but kingside castles and not Knight the
sea too and it seems like black
accomplished everything he's gonna trade
even more material and then he's gonna
have a good game but there is one move
that he missed so feel free to pause the
video and try to figure out this move
that just makes uh Black's entire
position fall apart while I give you a
couple of seconds
um
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on calculating all
of this as it's quite a lot to calculate
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show it is Ponta D6 that's the
move that black overlooked when he went
for this nice uh uh Knights the A6 the
B4 to C2 idea and now the problem is you
you can't just trade if you play Knight
captures on A1 Queen capture 78 okay you
can bring your knight back into the game
but now it's a matter of the very simple
Bishop captures Bishop captures and
Knight to E4 and the the black king is
uh stuck in the in the open the D6 Pawn
is nicely defended and you don't really
have a good move how do you how do you
place a queen captures on A6 is coming
then you have to worry about the these
two pass points and if you try to defend
this uh then even Rook to C1 just wins
the game because you can't move the
Knight if you move the Knight and Rook
to C7 wins the queen so it's completely
unplayable uh in the game uh it wasn't
played in the game Bishop the A6 was
played strongest way to play this is
Bishop D7 and I'm just going to show
what happens because a white will have
to work for his meal but it's still it
still is winning Bishop captures Bishop
captures now Rook 8 to D1 you want your
d-pawn uh defended at all cost Rook to
B8 getting the Rook out of Harm's Way
and also going after the B2 Pawn but now
just Rook to D2 you attack the Knight
you prefer to double up on the D file
and there's no good way to to actually
play this Knight is always coming to D5
to E4 for example if you capture on B2
Knight to D5 and now if Rook captures I
need to You're Gonna Play Knight
captures and F6 and after Queen captures
now you're gonna play Queen to E4 and it
uh uh some point black will lose
material now the Knight is defended you
can play uh Queen to E6 also you can
offer offer a queen trade because a
queen can't capture first The Rook has
the capture first now let's say queen F3
check Queen to F6 Queen to B3 check now
connects with the Rook nicely so you
block Queen to East 6 and now Queen to
C3 and now there's no good way to attack
the uh to attack the the queen and the
Knight will hang so you're gonna see
something like Quinta E4 defending the
knight uh F3 and there's uh no way to
continue the defending the Knight you're
gonna have to move some like Queen to B4
Rook captures Queen captures through
captors and now you're just up the
exchanger you're up a pawn of course
this is now uh completely winning for uh
lupuscu so instead after D6 with Bishop
to A6 now attacking the rook and now
Bishop captures on F6 with Bishop
captures now Rook 8 to C1
offering a trade of works if a bishop
captures then you're gonna capture on C2
or even better with Bishop captures you
can play King characters on F1 and now
after the Knight moves the attacks the
queen queen to D5 with checking to f8
and now Knight to the E4 again
um just unplayable the the bishop is
saying if you move the bishop then the
Knight is hanging if you move the queen
then The Rook is hanging there's still
the pass Pawn Rook is coming to C7
Checkmate will be in the air uh uh
completely winning for white so in the
game Rook 8 to C1 Knight to D4 was
played attacking the queen here and now
just Queen to D5 with check King to G7
Rook after D1 and he was in this
position on move 22 that Ahmad resigned
to the game uh as there is nothing more
uh to be done here the Knight really has
nowhere to go all of the squares are
taken Rook captures and D4 is coming on
the next move and it's a very hard to
uh to try something if you go Knight to
F5 then Knight the E4 then Rook to C7
all of the all of the standard ideas
that are are that have already been
played in front this year you can
capture play D7 uh it's just uh
completely unplayable uh for black for
example Queen to d8 Knight characters
now the queen cannot capture because you
promote the pawn so King has to capture
Knights the queen to C6 with check will
pick up the bishop on A6 and uh it's
only one of the lines but uh absolutely
everything here is winning so this is
one of the games uh from the penultimate
round I I really wanted to show you
because it's such a nice way to beat the
the benoni defense and maybe if you
enjoy uh playing against the benoni and
you uh maybe also uh that haven't uh
thought of maybe the postponing your
castling and just going for Bishop to D3
and then trying this very nice line you
can see that very good things happen uh
for for white in this line and it's not
like it's very risky uh if you if you
ask the engine it will always give white
like a plus plus 0.7 plus one advantage
of course if you allow it to Crunch the
numbers long enough it's going to be
zero zero zero zero but you know it's
perfectly fine to go for it so if you
enjoy it do try it maybe it works out
for you as well uh it all came down to
this uh wonderful past the d-pawn and
then after D6 was played that's just it
no no uh the the point of no return for
black
uh so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it very nicely done by
Constantinople uh
uh sorry about that in the lead uh we
still have uh a tie it's Alexis Arana
and kiroshimchenko and going into the
final round sarana will face chefchenko
so uh we couldn't ask for a better uh
final round of the European individual
Championship we're the only two players
on eight out of eight sarana and
chefchenko will will face each other so
uh probably if it's not going to be an
absolute snooze Fest uh it is the game
I'm I'm going to cover first from uh the
final round uh so that's the game hope
you guys enjoyed it good luck uh
fighting in the benoni it's a wild
opening
um uh many uh great players have played
it uh Bobby Fischer even like I said uh
I never lost the game with it throughout
his entire career only that one game uh
against pozky in 1992 in in uh Stefan uh
so yeah it's a wonderful opening but if
you uh if you try too much you might you
might get burned uh so yeah I once again
hope you enjoyed it I would like to wish
a very happy birthday to Otto and I
would like to thank Joe Wilders Ryan
Kevin or Bob bosho and an anonymous
person for your contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing to check up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the Chess World thank you all I will see
you soon and have an excellent rest of
your day